[Music]
hey there Welcome to our broadcast and
St technology Trends my name is l Marina
and I'll be your host today so without
further Ado let's dive into today
episode and embark on a great journey
together get ready to be engaged
entertained and inspired today's topic
will be about riding the techway cool
Trends and changing our world from AI to
blockchain and Beyond this Innovation
are reshaping how we live work and
play I have a few examples about
technology trends that I will explain
more specifically one of them is AI and
machine learning what is AI and machine
learning for example imagine having a
super smart body who helps you with
everything that's AI for you Ai and
machine learning are
everywhere we've got viral PALS like
Siri and Alexa and self-driving cars are
becoming a
reality they are making things more
convenient and efficient we are talking
smarter chatbots predictive analysts and
even personalized Netflix
recommendations after the AI and machine
learning the second one is Internet of
Things everything's getting
connecting for example your home your
car your fridge and even the small thing
like toothbrush cannot talk to each
other Internet of
Things is all about connecting everyday
objects to the internet small
thermostats like Nest managed your homes
temperature for you Citywide systems
make traffic smooth and garbage
collector more efficient but it's not
all roses we need to be mindful of data
privacy and security one of the most
useful things nowadays is 5G
previously maybe you have thought that
4G was false and maybe you thought that
it was the most important Discovery but
actually 5G is like a speed demon it's
not just about Foster cat videos it's
the backbone for cool stuff your doctor
can do remote checkups with ease thanks
to Smooth video calls
however we need to ensure everyone get
access to this lightning F internet over
technology Trends what we are going to
discuss is blockchain what digital
logbox Beyond Bitcoin blockchain is
making a splash it's like a super secure
transparent Ledger nowadays companies
are using it to track products in Supply
chains and even making voting more
secure think of it as a digital TR serup
after
blockchain where over technology Trends
is quantum Computing what is quantum
Computing quantum computers are like
regular comput computers on
seds uh they use cits which can be in
many states at once
we are set to solve problems we couldn't
dream of tackling before Quantum
Computing has the potential to
revolutionize Fields like cryptography
and Drug Discovery one of the technology
trends that helps you is wearables your
personal health coach Smartwatch and
fitness trackers have become our
personal health coaches they keep tabs
on your
stups Hur rate and even sleep we have
handy for tracking your health and
staying in shape but we need to think
about privacy when our health data is at
stake another technology Trend that is
happening now is AR and VR
augmented reality and visual reality are
taking us to new worlds AR layers
digital info onto a real world like
Pokemon go VR immerses you in a whole
new universe they are not just for
gaming they are used for education
training and even remote work imagine a
10 in a meeting in your pgs thanks to VR
renewable energy green power to the
rescue our world is facing climate
change the renewable energy is the hero
we need solar and wind power along with
Advanced Energy storage and leading or
leading the charge this technology helps
reduce carbon emissions and move us
toward a green cleaner more
sustainable future perhaps you have not
heard of this but this is a game changer
in technology Trends Health Tech and
tele medicine tele medicine is one where
R making Health Care accessible and
convenient during the pandemic it was a
Lifeline now Health tech devices and
apps or being used for everything from M
monitoring chronic diseases to early
detection Robotics are robotic friends
robots are working side by side with us
in factories and even assisting in
surgeries in retail and Hospitality
service robots are becoming common while
they boost productivity we need need to
adapt to a changing job landscape
security is also a very important issue
with more technology comes more cyber
threats we need cyber Security Experts
to protect our data and privacy Ai and
machine learning are helping but we must
stay wigant in the digital age the next
one is smart cities smart cities are all
about using technology to make our
cities more efficient and liable they
optimize traffic energy use waste
management and Public Safety we are
shaping our Urban future and
making our cities more
sustainable something is
surrounding us all the times are
vehicles but in the future we will have
autonomous vehicles self drivings cars
and drones are no longer safei they
could make our roads safer and reduce
traffic jems but we also need to think
about Job loses and ethical dams when it
comes to decision making during
emergencies in conclusion we are living
in exciting time where technology Trends
are driving change and
Innovation we are the Forefront of a
digital Revolution but we also need to
navigate challenges like privacy F and
job displacement by staying informed and
embracing these Trends responsibly we
can ride the tech wave to a brighter
more connected future thank you so much
for joining us to this episode of riding
the tech wave cool trans changing our
world it's been an incredible journey
and we are so glad on your came along
for a ride until the next time take
care
that